[Música]
te imaginaste alguna vez con 60 70 80 90
100 años
qué imagen te devuelve el espejo que
sentís que deseas
cuáles son tus proyectos
estas no son preguntas que nos hagamos
todos los días de hecho yo tampoco me
las hacía hasta que comencé a trabajar
en un lugar lleno de personas mayores
que eligen hacer talleres culturales
recreativos educativos
deportivos
fue gracias a esa experiencia
que me di cuenta de que las ideas que yo
tenía sobre la vejez no coincidían con
la realidad
la realidad tenía nombre propio se
llamaba se llama susana que en el taller
de tenis de mesa conoció a ernesto
al poco tiempo se pusieron de novios
luego se casaron y hoy eligen vivir en
casas separadas
katy
llegó
encorvada apoyada en su bastón
acompañada de su hija y de su cuidadora
que hoy no pueden creer que sea la
protagonista de la agrupación de
percusión fuerza mayor
envejeció creyendo que nunca iba a poder
cantar
yo fui testigo
de la primera vez que a sus 78 años
interpretó honrar la vida de eladia
blázquez
juan se enamoró de roberto en el taller
de portugués hoy viven juntos
el envejecimiento es un proceso
no nos convertimos en personas mayores
de un día para el otro
envejecer es vivir vivir es envejecer
porque nos cuesta tanto entonces
conectar con un proceso tan natural tan
humano como el proceso de envejecimiento
quizás algo de responsabilidad tenga la
cultura esta cultura de la impaciencia
del descarte de la inmediatez de esta
cultura self y que permanentemente
intenta filtrar borrar las huellas del
paso del tiempo
yo tenía miedo
de envejecer en una cultura que me
descarte que me des en poder que me
invisibiliza que no valore mi impronta
mi recorrido todo lo que tengo para
ofrecer
y fue por eso que sentí que algo tenía
que hacer
así nació el club de la porota una
propuesta de comunicación que intenta
darle voz a las personas mayores reales
porota es un arquetipo de mujer mayor
que a sus 70 años
elige compartir sus vivencias y
experiencias
porque entiende que éste también es su
presente
las reflexiones de porota se divulgan
por las redes sociales por los medios de
comunicación
llegaron a tantas personas que hoy somos
una comunidad diversa como la vejez
intergeneracional como la vida
una comunidad que pretende crear nuevos
estereotipos muchos más positivos sobre
la vejez y el envejecimiento como rosa
que a sus 80 años se acaba de inscribir
en la universidad o catalina que en
medio de la pandemia eligió irse a vivir
al campo con su mejor amiga o como
carlos que fundó una escuela y
actualmente la sigue dirigiendo o como
carmen que elige cuidar a sus nietos
nietas hacer un taller de computación y
vídeos en tick tock
pensar en una persona mayor rápido la
primera que se te venga a la mente
acaso esa persona es alguien
desvitalizado desconectado con la vida
lo más probable es que no
porque las ideas que tenemos de la vejez
no representan la realidad de las
personas mayores que nos rodean
yo estoy segura
que no le tenemos miedo a la vejez a lo
que más le tememos son a las ideas
representaciones prejuicios culturales
mentales que vamos construyendo
a veces no es sinónimo de
enfermedad de deterioro de pérdidas que
hoy podamos pensar nos mayores es una
verdadera conquista de la humanidad el
siglo 21 es el siglo del envejecimiento
poblacional estamos invitados a vivir
estamos invitados a conectar con la vida
con la belleza que nos habita
los deseos los proyectos los anhelos la
potencia no entienden de edades
las personas mayores de hoy sos vos
con más años
cuando pienses en la vejez cuando
juzgues a una persona por su edad
piensa en cómo te gustaría que te traten
dentro de 10 15 20 25 años
el camino de tu vejez lo construir hoy
por otra por otra soy yo por otra sos
vos por otras somos todas las personas
envejecientes
te imaginaste alguna vez con 60 80 100
años
qué imagen te devuelve el espejo
que deseas que sentís
como te tratan
gracias
[Música]